that's a real muscle class real muscle
flash roughly the size of the gun
everybody's like no way that's too big
it's like no
it's not
[Music]
cause that gives us four days we can i
think we can finish all this between the
three of us we can finish all this
before this okay cool well that's the
case let's just talk a little bit about
the look of the muzzle flashes and flood
hits and all kind of stuff am i right
ladies
[Applause]
we were looking at the clip from eric
andre show you know when they had the
blood hits they basically had an effect
on like the person's shirt where like it
would bulge it up you know because
that's the squib kind of going off you
know and then eventually that would
burst so you kind of get the actual like
bullet hit effect and all kind of red
and gooey in there and then after it
burst you kind of have the
splat you know a blood that didn't go
out very far you know basically like
something you get from the detonation
films hemoglobin and on top of that you
get like a mist spray that would go out
really far really fast looking at the
timing of our blood it's not the knife
it's close to the actual bullet hits you
want to make sure the timing and the
distance travel matches the uh it's on
the eric andre clip yeah doing a frame
by frame like seeing in one frame smoke
shoots out roughly three feet you know
or two feet or something like that you
want to make sure that the speed of our
miss hits i mean you haven't pulled up
right there which is awesome you want to
make sure the speed and the scale that
we have matches what's in there because
then we'll know the motion is realistic
yeah now in regards to the muzzle
flashes there's a good rule of thumb
that sam and i have always followed
which is basically to say the size of
your muzzle flash is roughly two-thirds
the size of your gun when it's like
pistols roughly the size of your pistol
but like if somebody has like a big
assault rifle it's basically the
distance from where the bullet sits in
the gun to where it exits the gun is
roughly the size of what your muzzle
flash should be
coming out of the gun take note that
that first ring with the muzzle flash
there is no smoke because the muzzle
flash is the smoke you know the muzzle
flash is just the gases that are still
hot and glowing in plasma state
basically so you won't have any smoke
when you have a muzzle flash from the
frame and the next frame once there's no
more muzzle flash you have to imagine
that this gas is expanded even further
and basically travels out in the next
frame to be twice the distance of what
the first muzzle flash was so there we
go see how big it is the first frame of
smoke roughly twice the length of the
gun
and then now third frame it's three
times the length of the gun like see how
big it gets how fast it's very light
also which is worth noting it's a very
clean burning gun it's actually a second
uh burst right there now
let's travel this farm one frame didn't
even see the flash and that
force of the smoke traveling that far is
what makes guns feel powerful in film
that's why fake muscle flashes usually
look like crap it's because they don't
get the smoke right because you need to
imply that there's something inside that
gun that has expanded fast from the
speed of sound
so there's some great smoke reference
right there you know it expands a little
bit from different rate here it's like
here than here than here and here it's
all about how it spits that smoke out
that's the other thing like somebody's
shooting next to something adding a
little bit of dust flying off the thing
is great but the lighting also really
adds a lot but you can really see how
much it lights up the scene there that's
a real muzzle flash a real muzzle flash
roughly the size of the gun everybody's
like no way that's too big no
it's not people also get shutter speed
wrong if there's a lot of motion blur
make sure the edge of your muzzle flash
is fuzzy if it's really really sharp
maybe try to pull it in a little bit but
for the most part fuzzy looks okay you
don't want blown out muzzle flashes when
you're feeling the sunlight because
you're already exposed for sunlight so
your muzzle flashes are going to be
softer a little bit more transparent and
more colored because you're basically
it's like exposing for fire yeah not
having every muzzle flash be a full
muzzle flash also makes things look more
real like sometimes you have one frame
where it's a full muzzle flash in the
next frame you're getting just like the
little bits of like fire like right at
the tip of the muzzle flash like you
want to capture a little bit of chaos
when you're composing muzzle flashes
we're not every frame is a perfect
muzzle right because it's like the
firing rate of guns doesn't necessarily
match up with the frame rate of video
yep exactly
boom
yeah wait that's so much bigger than the
game
that's real
it looks like a effects element but it's
real blank firing guns uh have bigger
muzzle flashes than no guns because
there's no bullet what would you
recommend for smoke elements like the
motion of this pretty good for a muzzle
flash smoke right you know it comes out
pretty fast like if your muzzle flash is
like this big
you know that works about but you have
to keep in mind your scale a lot of
people composite these wrong you know
shot this far so they make the gun this
big you know but no like a person is
like this tall the size of a muzzle
flash like the gun's like this big that
much smoke so it's kind of low res for
how big it is but usually they're really
transparent so it doesn't really matter
this is a real oozy right there for
unreal muzzle flashes and he was just
firing it one-handed like a real one
yeah
once again there's no uh oh here's some
real good sparks these are all real
sparks i think the thing that sparked
stock footage especially like cg sparks
is they never make a little burst at the
end when spark burns out and the little
like glowing pellet pops like how you
get a little like fuzzy bursts on the
edge of sparks yeah and so all like
sparks have that feeling where it's a
straight line
and cg sparks never get that right
because they never make their particles
pop into more particles in a subframe
animation that's not sylvester stallone
stunt double by the way it's just a
paintball so what yeah so what they're
doing for those uh sparks is they're
actually filling paintballs with
zirconium which when it hits stuff will
spark so they're literally shooting
paintball spark things that create real
sparks that's so dope yeah it's super
cool
[Laughter]
oh
all that light wrap and and glow and
reflections now see a little bit of
gunpowder coming out yeah muzzle flashes
are dirty you know so you want to kind
of like make it dirty and not too clean
so i make good muzzle flashes people do
the research it's really easy
like you can go to youtube and you type
in gun
and you'll find muscle flash reference
[Music]
[Music]
you